so right over here i have the molecular
formula for glucose and so let's just
say that i had a sample of pure glucose
right over here this is my little pile
of glucose i'm not even going to tell
you it's mass but based on the molecular
formula can you figure out the
percentage
of carbon by mass of my sample pause
this video and think about it and as a
hint i've given you the average atomic
masses of carbon hydrogen and oxygen
all right now let's work through this
together now the reason why the the
amount of glucose doesn't matter is
because the percent carbon by mass
should be the same regardless of the
amount but to help us think this through
we can imagine amount let's say let's
say let's just assume that this is a
mole this is a mole of glucose
so one way we could think about it is we
say okay for every mole of glucose we
have six moles of carbon because every
glucose molecule has six carbon atoms so
we could say what is going to be the
mass
of six moles of carbon
divided by
the mass
of one
mole of glucose and once again the
reason why it's six moles of carbon
divided by one mole of glucose is
because this if we assume this is a mole
of glucose every molecule of glucose has
six carbons so it's going to be six
times as many carbon atoms or six moles
of carbon
now what is this going to be
well this is going to be equal to
it's going to be in our numerator we're
going to have 6
moles
of carbon
times the molar mass of carbon well
what's that going to be well we can get
that from the average atomic mass of
carbon if the average atomic mass is
12.01 universal atomic mass units the
molar mass is going to be 12.01
grams per mole of carbon
so times
12.01
grams per mole
of carbon and notice the numerator will
just be left with grams
and then in the denominator
what are we going to have
well the mass of one mole of glucose for
every glucose molecule we have six
carbons 12 hydrogens and six oxygens so
it's going to be the mass of 6 moles of
carbon 12 moles of hydrogen and 6 moles
of oxygen
so it's going to be what we just had up
here it's going to be 6 moles of carbon
times the molar mass of carbon 12.01
grams per mole of carbon
to that we are going to add
the
mass of 12 moles of hydrogen so 12
moles of hydrogen times the molar mass
of hydrogen which is going to be 1.008
grams per
mole of hydrogen
plus
6 moles of oxygen
times the molar mass of oxygen which is
going to be 16.00
grams per mole of oxygen and the good
thing is down here the units cancel out
so we're left with just grams in the
denominator and that makes sense we're
going to end up with grams in the
numerator grams and denominator the
units will cancel out and we'll get a
pure percentage at the end
so let's see in the numerator 6 times
12.01 is 72.06
and then
in
the denominator i'm just going to do the
pure calculation first and then i'm
going to worry about significant figures
so the denominator we have
72.06
plus see 12 times 1.008 is 12.096
and then we have
plus
6 times 16 is 96.00
zero
and this will be equal to
72 if we're just thinking about the pure
calculation before we think about
significant figures 72.06
divided by let's see if i had 72 to 12 i
get 84 plus 96 i get
180.156 did i do
that right if i were to just add up
everything not even think about
significant figures so we can type this
into a calculator but we should remind
ourselves that our final answer should
have no more than four significant
figures because even down here if we
were just doing this blue calculation
here that should only have four
significant figures it would have gotten
us to the hundreds place and so when we
add things together we should get no
more than the hundredths place but even
if we rounded over there for significant
figures purposes we would still have
at least four we would actually have
five significant figures so this four
significant figures is our significant
figures limiting factor so we just have
to calculate this and round to four
significant figures
72.06 divided by 180
is equal to and if you round to four
significant figures this will be point
four zero zero zero
so this will be i'll say approximately
equal to zero point four
zero
or we could say 40
or 40.00 percent carbon by mass when we
round to four significant figures and we
are done